6 25 on your friday morning it was
announced earlier this week that three
local schools have been named blue
ribbon schools by the u.s department of
education the principles couldn't be
prouder
starting with michael o'dowd from the
pinecrest academy in sporada campus the
teachers the students the parents are
just elated right now it's really
exciting to see
to get a national recognition of
what they've been working so hard for
over the past five years and part of
that includes the last 18 months over
the pandemic and jennifer reynolds from
charlotte hill elementary who says it's
all about the kids doesn't matter if
you're a second language learner
individual with a disability
if your family has some type of
financial problem what matters is that
you are who you are we're going to find
your strengths we're going to build upon
them and we're going to help you reach
your potential speaking of the kids
robert solomon from lamping elementary
now that we've received this recognition
what's next how do we market this and
share this with our students so they
have an understanding what's happening
at the school that they should feel
fortunate to be part of because it
doesn't happen everywhere
absolutely so there's going to be a
ceremony in washington d.c in november
the principals pick up those awards and
all of them said they just can't wait to
share those awards with the teachers the
staffs and of course those blue ribbon
kids now if you know something that's
cool at school let us know about it head
to 8 newsnow dot com click on cool at
school that's under the community tab or
you can just send us an email cool at
school eightnewsnow.com